mills report contains some flash
photography
outside the house in bedfordshire where
captain tom had so often taken center
stage
his family took his place
a simple gesture celebrating the life
and achievements of their father
and grandfather a man they've done so
much to support
i invite members to know join me for a
minute silence to commemorate
sir tom's life and to pay our respects
to those who lost their lives
as a result of the covet and their
families and friends
earlier in the day parliament had fallen
silent
the prime minister inviting the country
to pay their respects
he inspired the very best in us all and
his legacy
will continue to do so for generations
to come i encourage
everyone to join in a national clap
for captain tom and all those health
workers
for whom he raised money at 6 p.m this
evening
echoing the idea of last year's clap for
carers
boris johnson and his fiancee carrie
started the applause
an enormous billboard lit up piccadilly
circus
as the leader of the opposition
kierstama also paid his respects
outside the hospital in bedford where
captain tom spent his final days
staff took a brief break to remember him
recognizing the lasting impact of the 33
million pounds that he raised for the
nhs
through his sponsored walk in harrogate
where last summer he'd inspected junior
soldiers as their honorary colonel
they joined the tribute to this
yorkshire military man
station staff at paddington station and
premier league footballers
also took time to pause
captain tom wouldn't have expected the
fanfare wouldn't have seen himself as
more important than the thousands of
others who've also lost their lives to
covid
a humble man who did inspire and for
many will forever
be a hero of our time rhiannon mills
sky news